[Musique]
l'excellence Orient
c'est donc le titre de ma conférence ce
soir
alors j'ai une relation un peu spéciale
avec ce mot depuis l'enfance
et surtout depuis que je sais lire
l'arabe
en fait mon prénom donc Faouzi veut dire
prédisposer la réussite et Anna
autant vous dire
que j'ai pas envie d'entendre un jour ce
gars porte mal son nom
très du plaisanterie
[Musique]
ce thème aujourd'hui
a provocation d'aborder l'excellence
excellence et l'échec dans l'entreprise
mais aussi à titre personnel
mon discours va être jalonné de date
et j'ai commencé par une première date
c'est le 11 mai 2022
c'est la première mondiale
de
où nous avons présenté notre prototype
en Italie chez pennyfarina en Italie
alors pour ceux qui ne savent pas fini
Farina c'est le plus grand studio design
automobile de l'histoire
90 ans d'existence ils ont designé plus
de 90% de Ferrari on voit sur les routes
ils ont fait rêver des millions de
personnes des milliers d'enfants créer
des millions de vocation
et ça a été notre premier choix
d'excellence
dans cette aventure
et
un événement important a eu lieu lors de
cette première mondiale
il y avait donc
une session de questions-réponses en
anglais avec les meilleurs journalistes
et plus importants journalistes
automobiles européens
nous étions dans une salle
au siège social de pinyparina à ma
gauche il y avait
précis je me suis un peu pensé d'esprit
et le bras en même temps en disant
est-ce que je rêve ou est-ce que je ceci
est
l'espace d'un instant je fais un bon 16
ans en arrière
septembre
je suis présent
à l'usine flanc de Renault avec mon père
qui a travaillé 35 ans
chez Renault et ils ont invité les
ouvriers et leurs familles à visiter
l'usine de Flins
donc évidemment qui était un grand passé
automobile j'ai pas hésité une seule
seconde
je n'étais pas directement
comme vous pouvez voir sur l'image le
style vestimentaire n'était pas encore
bon mais l'ambition était déjà là
deux choses m'ont vraiment frappé
durant cette visite la première chose
c'est l'usine en elle-même c'est sombre
très bruyant
même pesant surtout quand à l'époque
j'avais seulement 13 ans
et une image m'a fortement marqué
ont visité l'usine assemblage à l'étage
et au rez-de-chaussée on voyait les
usines les employés qui assemblaient les
pièces et je voyais un ouvrier qui avait
la cinquantaine et 61 proche de la
retraite enfin la retraite d'avant
et il faisait deux pièces d'affilée
pour avoir ne serait-ce que 30 secondes
de répit
c'est à dire qui sans presser de faire
deux pièces au lieu d'une pour arracher
30 secondes de liberté
ce sentiment a été
assez marquant pour moi
et l'autre scène marquant
c'est un homme dans la force de l'âge
environ 40 ans qui connaissait mon père
et donc ils discute et il vient me voir
il me dit à ce moment-là
c'est l'arme commence à couler alors moi
je suis étonné je vois un homme un bon
gaillard pleurer rapidement je me
demande pourquoi et il me dit
travail à l'école ne finit pas comme
nous
durant entendre et dur à voir d'un homme
jeune qui l'usine à
a été assez violent
ces deux événements m'ont profondément
marqué
dans ma vision des choses et dans ma
quête de l'excellence
à ce moment là nous étions en septembre
2005 on va faire un bon 17 ans après
Porte de Versailles
au Mondial de l'Automobile de Paris
nous avons eu la chance de pouvoir
présenter notre concept une prototype
sur un stand de près de 400 mètres
carrés face à des grands constructeurs
chinois asiatiques et les constructeurs
classiques européens
c'est vrai que moi qui allais au milieu
de l'auto tous les deux ans en tant que
fan c'était
juste inimaginable
le 17 octobre c'était la journée presse
le lendemain c'était ouvert au public
j'ai eu la chance d'avoir mon père qui a
pu venir évidemment
peu de mots ont pu sortir de sa bouche
les yeux ont parlé
c'est compliqué de poser des mots d'un
ouvrier qui voit son fils fait Marc
automobile exposé devant son ancien
employeur
maintenant je vais vous parler
d'un nombre
250 euros
c'est le montant avec lequel j'ai
commencé l'entrepreneuriat en 2013 avec
un ami
on a créé une entreprise avec 500 euros
de capital à 55 ans c'était mignon
et ma rencontre
savez on a beaucoup de témoignages
entrepreneurs on dit qu'il a commencé de
rien avec rien
et souvent on apprend que
un ou trois ans plus tard qu'il a
commencé avec un million d'euros
évidemment c'est pas la même histoire
c'est une chance vous recommencer qu'un
capital financier mais pour beaucoup
d'entre nous et beaucoup de jeunes
talents on commence avec peu de moyens
par contre j'avais un A7 j'avais un
natif qui lui permet de commencer
sans grand moyen
si cette état des états d'esprit ce
mindset de faire les choses bien de
l'excellence
une phrase qu'on me répétait souvent
quand tu fais quelque chose fait le bien
évidemment ce n'est pas suffisant mais
rien que le fait de faire quelque chose
au maximum ou permet de passer des
barrières les étapes très rapidement
finalement c'est quoi l'excellence c'est
quoi l'échec
il y a une phrase aussi importante
que je me répète tous les jours
c'est une phrase de l'ancien PDG de
Intel
qui dit le succès
amène l'auto-satisfaction
l'auto-saxon amène l'échec seuls les
paranoïaques survivent
finalement le succès c'est un état
excellent également on peut l'être un
moment on peut ne pas l'être et on garde
l'excellence grâce à une humilité
constante
et le point principal qu'on a tendance à
réduire c'est notre entourage et
l'impact qu'on les autres humains sur
nous
seul je n'ai rien fait ce projet c'est
l'addition de différents talents
d'une équipe excellente
c'est cette addition qui ont permis de
dépasser ses limites
finalement
l'échec qu'est-ce que c'est
l'échec c'est un sentiment
de regret de nos ne pas avoir fait le
maximum pour quelqu'un pour quelque
chose c'est uniquement ça l'échec ce
n'est pas raté
un lancement ou raté un une épreuve
c'est d'avoir ce sentiment de ne pas
être au bout des choses d'avoir tenté le
maximum et l'excellence
finalement c'est
de miroir et de se dire j'ai fait le
maximum j'ai fait j'ai poussé curseur le
plus loin possible ensuite le succès
c'est une question de destin
on a tendance à vouloir tout contrôler
nous humains mais on peut contrôler ce
qu'on fait ensuite le résultat des
points de beaucoup de paramètres
je vais
terminer par
vous donner ma vision de l'excellence
c'est
faire le maximum
afin de créer la voiture la plus
désirable au monde
tout en préservant l'environnement
et en préservant la santé mentale et
physique et futur employés de l'usine de
dynamique
merci
[Applaudissements]